Hey, what's going on? Oh, hey,
it's bill burn. It's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday, Monday,
March 23rd, 2015. How's it going?
How are you doing? Hopefully, hopefully
you're hearing this thing on time,
if not sooner. Last week I, um,
I recorded the thing on Sunday.
Then of course I brought the wrong
fucking why so I couldn't upload it right.
And then fucking I do my Thursday one.
My Internet just sucks in my,
I don't know what's going on, like in
my neighborhood. Right. They don't want,
you know, when they put those trees
up, it looks like a weird looking tree,
but she can't really tell unless you look
at it and it gives you good internet.
All in my neighborhood, they don't
want that. We know one kid in a fixed,
the Chegg, we did the Winch Cape
and your neighborhood. Right?
So we don't have one of those.
So my internet sucks a big bag of dicks.
So what I have to do now,
it just keeps getting worse by the week.
And, um, I don't know if this
is part of some other bullshit,
some big conglomerates buying up bandwidth
and all this shit where they try to
squeeze me down the fucking little
porthole. They want me to go down.
I don't even know if that's
under the same category.
That's just some shit that I heard
walking by a TV in an airport. All right.
So don't hold me to that.
Um,
all I know is now whenever
I do my fucking podcast,
what I have to do is I then have to jump
in the car after I uploaded and then
drive down to a local Starbucks
and I got to stand there,
you know, eating a Muffin, waiting for
the fucking thing to upload. Actually,
I'm not, I don't need an I not
eating a muffin. Alright. Oh,
Billy Gym rat, Huh? Oh, Billy squat face.
I'm going to the gym now for
fucking two weeks. And um, you know,
I fucked up yesterday.
A buddy of mine's parents were in town.
We went to this Greek restaurant like
a fucking horse. And uh, you know,
it's just, it's just fucking
my age. You just can't do that.
You can't deny that negates two
days of working out. But uh,
I'm still going to the gym.
I'm holding steady. I was at,
I was one 77.8 starting off at one 84.
I dropped seven pounds almost of
fucking lot more like six pounds.
And uh,
I'm not stopping and I'm going to keep
saying this because if I don't tell you
guys this, you won't hold it to me.
Hold with me. You won't hold me to it.
I got to get down to a buck 62 the last
time. Oh, whatever. Fucking waited.
His wife finally have a flat stomach or,
you know what I mean?
What I've always said,
all right,
there's standing up flat stomach,
there's lying down flat stomach,
and then the ultimate shape is
sitting down flat stomach, right?
The ultimate truth is when you sit
down and you look down, that's,
that's the fucking shape. Your rent.
And I got to tell you, I don't like it.
I don't like it at all.
So you wouldn't know by my coughing.
I haven't had a cigar in a fucking month.
And I like it.
I think I'm done with them for awhile.
I'm going to, I'm a smoke one new years,
my birthday and then like that big
college game I go to every year and then
that's fucking it.
You know what I mean?
I had this fucking cough for
like a few weeks, you know,
it was some sort of throat infection,
but I mentioned to the guy that I smoked
cigars and he took his little fucking
mirror and he was looking at the side
of my tongue for cancerous lesions that
immediately I'm just like, what
am I doing? What am I an asshole?
What do I get off smoking a cigar? Like
I just figured out the fucking economy,
you know, like I just, uh, you know,
carved a path towards world peace.
I have,
all I did was come up with more hateful,
hurtful, misinterpreted material.
That's all I've done. I don't
deserve a cigar. Um, so anyways,
I've been going to the gym.
I've just decided that going to the
gym is part of my day. All right.
It's not a part of my day that I
like, I don't like the gym, you know,
you know fucking sign they had on today.
Remember that song? Y'All ready for this?
Bap, bap, bap, bap. Not a fucker
thing. Y'All ready for this?
I'm going to start seeing my stupid
a dubstep shit. I fucked as it go.
Y'All ready for this Dan?
Nana,
Nan Nan and I can't remember how it goes.
It's like it always pleases fucking
awful keyboard and then it stops at some,
Duke asks you, are Y'all
ready for this? You know,
we play dad, they played Herbie Hancock.
They'll brocket, which you know,
I actually appreciate that song,
but I mean,
I just don't understand why the
music has to be so bad. So anyways,
I was going to the gym and I'm walking
to my car. I'm just muttering like,
I don't want to do this. I don't want
to do this. I don't want to do this.
And it turned into, I don't want to
do this. I don't want to do this.
I don't want to do this. But the
second I do this, it's over. All right,
second, I'm done. It's over.
That's what I just kept saying.
I don't want to do this. I don't want
to do this. I don't want to do this.
But the second it's done,
it's over and I'm fucking walking up
the steps to my gym outage and I knew
people fucking walking out of the gym too.
I'm so jealous of them that they had done,
you know,
and people coming out of the gym,
they were in a good mood.
They hold the fucking door for you
and shit. Big Smile. Hey Ho. Hey Pete,
you work it out on right people fucking
dragging ass walking into the gym.
They fucking opened.
They don't even look back at you.
They do everything with slam the
fucking door in your face, right.
Then you walk up to the
counter and he said,
little spunky perky little chick day
with their fucking pony tails pretending
she doesn't realize that she's of
dressed like a whore. You know,
like something you'd order.
You know what I mean?
What's with the fucking whore theme here?
You know,
I can't just show up with the hair
like an adult. Okay. This is how much?
Eight the gym.
I'm actually taking it out on this person
and she probably didn't look like that
at all, right? I just fucking hate
it. And then you go over to the map,
you're going to go stretch out. And what
happens every time you go over there,
some content is fucking and by con male
or female has sweated on the fucking map
and didn't even wipe it up. And even
if they did wipe it up, you see that.
You're like, well what the fuck
am I laying on here? Right.
I should know wore shorts.
Gross.
So,
um,
I dunno, but I haven't been in the
gym a while, but the gym etiquette,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
You know the deal,
like if you're using a machine, you
use it, then you stand up, right?
You sort of walk around a little bit
in case somebody else wants to use it.
I was doing legs today, legs and
edge, right? This fucking asshole.
I do a set of the things, you
know, you're sitting down,
you bring your fucking feed up
whenever you call those things.
And then I go over to do the ones where
you're doing the back of your legs.
And then I do the squat machine.
I'm going back again to the first one.
It's called doin a little cycle
there, right? One, two, three.
The quote was called BDP, right?
You got fucking three of them.
And I go back to the first one and this
is fucking jerk off finishes his set.
And then he's just sitting there staring
down at his fucking iPhone, you know,
and I didn't say anything because
the last time that happened,
I said to this lady, I said, Hey,
can I work in? She's like, oh ha.
And then say, I got my earbuds. I'm like,
can I work as set in? And she's like,
I only have two more. And
she just puts it back in. Ah,
I wanted to give her a fucking flare chop.
Right.
Right over the top of her fucking
breast assists, which you can't do that.
Get through that. Now they're out of
the house. They got jobs, they can vote.
It's fucking over. Um, there was a time
when they weren't even allowed to Jim's.
Um,
I don't know what he's,
I don't understand that person.
I don't understand the person that's
still uses the fucking stair master.
This fucking guy gets on. Right.
And you know those people,
when they get on the stairmaster
and they stand on it,
what happens is the fucking thing
starts going down to the ground.
That's when you supposed to step,
step up onto the other one.
They let it go all the way down to
the brown ground with both legs.
And then he'd just go meet me like
little step, little step, little step,
little step.
They're not doing anything.
And then they're just fucking like
clinging to the top of the machine.
Like they have boat capsized
and they're waiting.
They're waiting for their
turn to get yanked into the
coast guard chopper. Right.
It's just so,
and they'll fucking beyond the thing
hanging on it for like 20 minutes.
And it's like, dude,
you didn't do anything
other than make your arms go to sleep.
Oh I, I'm lashing out everyday everybody
cause I fucking can't stand it.
I'm so fucking mad at myself that I've
gotten myself into this fucking position
that I'm going to have to go there for
like two and a half months just to,
just to be acceptable looking.
I'm telling you, dude,
you eat your way in and out of
the gym, man. I swear to God. Oh,
belly fat face did a fucking number,
man,
the holidays and then that fucking world
tour actually did well on the world
tour. I was fucking hitting the,
uh, that was hitting the gyms.
I could just make a huge difference.
And then I went to New York and
it was just a fucking shit show.
You know what I mean?
You know, you get drunk.
All pizza tastes good when you're
drunk, you don't give a fuck. Right.
Go to those goddamned Delis,
get a bacon,
egg and cheese had fucking
two in the morning. Oh, that's
good, Bill. There you go.
We think that's going on right to your
fucking man titty. A freckled can't.
So I did that for, I dunno. I Dunno.
I don't even know how long
it started in November,
right before Thanksgiving I started,
you know,
you just start shifting around in
your chair and you feel it. Ah,
you're putting on a little weight there,
Bill. When are you going to do it?
Hello? Go the gym or want more. Fritos.
I was stuck in it.
The sugar,
salt addiction and had me when I
was writing on F is for family.
We have Frito Fridays.
We get a big giant bag and these fucking
awesome sandwiches. And it was great.
It was great until now. Now that
I'm on the elliptical, so, um,
I actually go into the gym and this is,
I actually to get an hour's worth the
cardio. If you're a Stephen Adler fan,
you can listen to basically, um, I list,
I don't know if I already told you this.
Well,
this is what I do when I have to
knock out an hour of cardio. Um,
obviously the towel goes over the timer
because I don't want to fucking look at
it.
And I put on civil war,
the only track that Steven played drums
on in the use your illusion albums.
And then I just listened appetite from
front to back and I basically look at it
this way. He got an hour, right?
Break it down to 15 minute quarters like
a game civil war into fucking welcome
to the jungle. And then
somewhere in a, it's so easy.
You got your first 15 minutes cause
civil wars along fucking song. All right,
it's like seven minutes Assam Shit.
What we've got here. All right.
And then you figure your next three,
which are a night train.
It's so easy.
And Mr Brownstone,
that takes you almost up to a half hour
and all depends on when you press play,
then you're into paradise city.
My Michelle to the Games have
forward then paradise city,
my Michelle and think about you.
All right.
Then you'll get coming up on 45 minutes.
You're in the final fucking stretch.
Then all it is is a sweet child.
You crazy. Uh, what's the other one?
Anything goes and then you'll warm down
is a rocket queen and you fucking done.
That's all I do and I'm getting sick
of that cause I keep fucking doing that
every God damn day and um,
I'll just have to sweat.
You got to have like a classic album
that you just like everything wired a
fucking wire and the musicians in the
band didn't put out some bullshit 40
minute album.
They actually put out a good
like 50 minutes of music and um,
I dunno at that point you're throwing one
of the fucking song and you're good to
go.
My born you with this shit.
Well that's how fucking
bought am at the God Damn Gym.
What's it with these meatheads
that walk around the garlic,
a gallon of fucking water.
Then they never sweating either.
They walk around,
they got that tape handle on it walking
around like a fucking ape. Right.
Is that what they're
going to drink all day?
I don't understand why they're doing that.
Although I do appreciate the beautiful
Leis and the spin class when I walked by
with a little half shirts on, that's kind
of Nice. Before I walk into the misery,
the fucking gym, no one I'm doing chest
that day and there's no fucking way.
The Bay, Oh, you know,
it was another fucking country move is
the guy who uses the bench for the bench
press to do like ab work and tricep dips
and then he just fucking sits there and
this,
yeah,
everybody goes for the fucking
weight bench. Nobody does squats.
You know what I mean? Go do your fucking
ab work on the squat machine. You can't.
Right. All right. That's
it. I'm done bitching.
Okay.
All right. And then we'd go,
Jesus fucking Christ. Oh, Bill.
Why did you do this to yourself?
You know, it's funny when
you, as I put on weight too,
I always go and putting on
weight and putting on weight,
and then I don't want to get on the
scale because I don't want to fucking see
what I already know. But if I just
get on the scale the second I felt it,
I'd feel disgusted halfway down the road
instead of being all the way down the
fucking road.
So anyways, that's it. I'm
done. I'm done. Fucking
done. Fucking rag and at this point, um,
okay.
Oh mean that fucking hand sanitizers
always out at the fucking gym heads.
He's Christ.
I'm not a gym guy.
I just don't fucking like are they going
to want to just file that fucking guy
watching Duke uh,
San Diego state right now and
that oca for whatever his name is.
He did that power Saul thing where
he dunks the ball, first of all,
he's like nine feet tall.
So it's like me Dunkin on a nerf hoop
and he dunks the ball after a fast break.
And, and what does he do after
he dunks the ball? He does
that stupid Yellen. Yeah.
Okay.
I think you ought to get teed up for that
technical foul for being a Douche.
What are you doing?
Quit acting like you're in
fucking brave heart. It just,
it drives me up the fight.
I don't know.
Yeah.
They never did that.
When I was a kid,
Larry Bird would fucking hit a three
pointer to win the game and I though stick
his, you know his index finger in the
air like, yeah, there you go. Number one.
It's over.
He just back pedaled down the accordion.
Ah,
okay.
Like he says, you know, half man, half
fucking, I dunno. We'll the beast.
Is that the right animal?
Oh Jesus.
This is all the misery of you're listening
to a sore old man who realizes he has
another two and a half months of fucking
work in the gym and he's ready to quit
right now and go get himself a cupcake.
By the way, I'm going to hand to the
Greeks, man, they've got great food,
don't they?
But I will tell you this,
they cannot make a dessert
to save their fucking lives.
Oh fuck you with the honey.
Jesus Christ.
Why don't you just take a honeycomb and
roll it in flour and throw it at me?
It's just,
it just tastes like ass.
It's like they take wallpaper and they
layer it up with honey in the middle of
it. That's what fucking Buck Lavaca is a
via however the fuck you say everything
else though. Outstanding. Maybe
that's where I need to live.
Maybe I should go move to Greece.
I'd never get dessert.
Not Cause I don't want it. It's
because they don't make a good dessert.
And then I would be
cutting those calories out.
Then I could finish my dinner and after
I was done dinner and they'd be like,
do you want, do you want dessert? I'd
be like, no. When they go, no, no.
I don't know when they walk away and
go like, I just did something amazing.
Yeah.
Does that work for you? Well, I
don't give a fuck. It works for me.
What's with your attitude this
week? Huh? What happened to you?
What'd you do this weekend that
makes you feel so God damn important?
Did you fill out your brackets?
Um,
so anyways, chases Christ.
You know what this is,
is I have so much shit I have
to fucking do today and uh,
and study for my fucking examine
the bubble guys. I'm in a bubble.
I don't know when I'm taking the test,
but a for the helicopter license. But uh,
I am in the bubble right now on testing
every day that e six B is my fucking
bitch right now.
It's my bitch.
I that thing I fucking couldn't stay in
that little stupid computer thing with
the God damn wheel. And after a
while, once you start figuring out,
you really appreciate the
genius of whoever it is that
came up with that thing.
I'll tell you, whoever came up with that
thing, if he did it while TV existed,
that's one of the smartest human
beings that ever lived, you know?
Yeah.
I'm going to go out on a limb and I'm
going to say a man is the person that came
up with that.
And the only reason why it wasn't a woman
was because of you fill in the blank.
You fill in the blank with the excuse.
Okay?
Because we're not allowed to play
with paper during that decade.
Okay?
This has nothing to do with sexism.
This has to do with me.
I fucking hate going to the gym. Don't
let go into jail. I don't want to do this.
I don't want to do this second. I
get it done. It's fucking over. Um,
anyways, what else?
Jesus Christ my Bruins.
A fucking rip in my hat out right now,
you know.
Right when I thought they were putting it
back together. We've got the capital's,
we got Ottawa, we got big games and
we just fucking lose all of them.
I haven't even seen the auto a game. I
was working that night and I just, I,
you know,
I followed the Bruins on my phone and I
just kept seeing how anytime there's 10
goals in a game as a pretty insane
game, I have it on. I have a DV Ad,
I'm going to watch it as much
as it's going to kill me,
but even last night we fucking lost
and over time to the fucking, uh,
Florida panthers in Ottawa one against
and now like, I don't know, I mean
Stan exam, but we're like the AC
by the skinning skin of our teeth.
Um, I dunno. Oh Shit.
Were playing Tampa Bay right now
or coming up? You got a fucking,
Tampa Bay is tough too. Ah,
cool. My kindle, we don't,
we don't have it this year.
I thought we were getting hard.
I thought we were going to be right.
Bruins face lightning with one point
lead for second wild card in the east.
Jesus Christ. I still think
the winter comes from the West.
What do you guys think?
Still think that better. Um,
speaking of hockey,
I was hanging out with Joe Barton,
Nick Rosebowl tailgate legend
Joe Barton neck and um,
he said gun to his head,
he was picking the Blackhawks and
he said maybe Saint Louis Blues.
I don't want to misquote him, but, uh,
if you want to hear the best
hockey show that I know of a,
you got to listen to his, uh, his puck
off podcasts, Joe Barton, nick, uh,
it's one of my favorites. And even
though he'd fucking rip the Bruins apart,
I couldn't argue with a lot of what he
was saying. But, um, I think this week,
rumor has it and he might be going
at his own Pittsburgh Penguins,
so we'll see what happens with
that. But, uh, but anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these every God damn week,
and then I check in on you on
Thursdays. That's how it works. And, um,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast
without having to give me a fucking dime
and feel good about yourself,
Sam,
you're going to Amazon rather than going
straight to amazon.com just go to my
website,
[inaudible] dot com click on the march
page and then click on the Amazon link
and they give me credit for driving
traffic to their website. That's,
it doesn't cost you any extra
money. No nothing, no Nada,
no nothing, right? So if you
would like to do that, uh,
I would really appreciate it.
And with that,
let's get to a little bit of advertising
here for this week. All right,
trunk club, everybody, Trunk,
T R U N K Trunk Trunk Club.
Guys,
you might hate shopping, but you
still want to look good, right?
What did,
you could snap your fingers and have a
trunk full of clothes that fit perfectly
and make you look amazing.
You're gonna love what gets delivered to
you from Trunk club@trunkclub.com slash
burr. You're, you answer a few
simple questions about your look,
your style and size. Yeah. God
can only imagine those questions.
I like to tell the world that I'm off
for something, but I'm kind of shy.
That's a no name Izod
if I ever heard of it.
And then they assign a real
person who helps to style you.
They email you a list of clothes,
they recommend a sending you.
You approve them at no cost to you.
They ship you a trunk full of fresh,
new clothes to your doors. Try
them on, keep what you want,
send back what you don't in,
they're prepared. Box. That's it.
It's a better wardrobe.
And then you could pick out yourself
in minutes that I mentioned.
The services free, your stylist, the
shopping, the box, even the shipping,
all 100% free when you go
to trunk club.com/berg when
and how the fuck do they
make money? Only pay for
the clothes you keep. Oh,
is that where you put your
hidden charges? No, no,
no ongoing subscription. No
hidden charges. No malls. Yeah,
there is hidden charges.
Give me a fucking break if you're not
going to charge me for the shipping.
For the box or the stylist. Yeah, it,
you just put all those charges in the
shirt. All right, let's keep going.
Only pay for the clothes you keep. No
ongoing then the bed. No hidden charges.
No malls. Just great clothes.
Handpicked for your style. Um,
they're claiming that I used it. I have
not used it, but I got to tell you,
if I was younger, I would use
it. I don't need to use it.
I already have a woman in my life. It's
fucking over. I, this is for guys, right?
You're going out there,
you're striking out. You know,
you thinking it's your opening line.
It isn't.
It's the fact that one of your side of
your college is standing up and the other
isn't and you need a brand new shirt.
Trunk Club is to get your trunk
Outta your fucking closet,
if you know what I mean. Hockey,
a fucking little elephant. Dick.
Going in and out of something that you
enjoy feeling the experience of, of,
of course, all of this and
consensual one. It'd be wonderful.
Do that with a fresh new shirt and
jeans on, right down to your me undies.
So you go to trunk club.com/birth then
you don't have to go to a mall. You guys,
you know something. So he brought
this up. What? I advertise on this,
you're gradually going to become um,
a gore of phobic.
Okay?
No, that's not true. You put
clothes on and go see people.
You don't have to go outside
to get shaved. You know,
you don't have to go and you don't
have to go to the post office.
You don't have to buy
razor blades anymore.
You don't have to go shopping for clothes.
Funny and pitch pissed the
people off at nature box.
You wouldn't have to get food
either. Draft Kings, oh good.
Become a fucking gambler to draft kinks.
Draft kings.com spring training is
underway and that that can only mean one
thing. Baseball season is
almost here. It's right there.
And there's never been a better
time to check out a draft.
kings.com America's favorite daily
fantasy baseball site where you could when
huge cast prices every day.
Daily fantasy means no
season long commitments.
No slogging through a long season to
collect your winnings. Just instant cash,
your fucking age. Instant
gratification. It's like a new season.
Every time you play simply pick two
pitches and eight position players stay
under the salary cap and you could be on
your way to a massive pay day that she
sounds. You know something? I never been
into fantasy but actually sounds cool.
You picked two pictures in a position.
Players and he got to stay under the
salary cap. That's where they you right?
Cause you've just pick all the
best guys not on have. Fuck you.
You know what that is
staying under the salary cap.
Those are the green numbers
in roulette right there.
And that's what throws the
whole thing out of whack though.
There's been 11 rides in a row.
We got a berry black,
green fuck Sierra.
Please don't use that language in here.
Fuck you talking about. I'm
sitting next to a call. Girl,
let's go with Suck my Dick
for 20 bucks. Okay, sir,
please collect your check
some leaf. Um, in fact,
draft kings has already crowned
over a dozen millionaires,
hundreds of thousands
of fantasy sports fans.
Just like you have cashed in a
draft kinks. Now it's your turn.
Hurry to drive a car.
Call to action.
How are you to draft kings.com now
and use Promo code defense too,
by the way, that's se not CE.
Okay. Defense, d, e,F , e n s,
e Delta Echo,
Foxtrot Echo,
November Sierra echo to play for free
and a hundred thousand dollar fantasy
baseball contest on opening day. That's
pretty cool. Opening Day. You can,
when you sell for a hundred
grand, which you know, you know,
it was about 45 grand after taxes.
First place takes home $10,000.
Use Promo code defense for
entry now@draftkings.com
draftkings.com that's draft
kings.com.
All right, let's do one more here. What
are these? What do you say? What do you,
oh no, am I got four for the week.
We'll go. We'll do two and window.
We'll break it up.
Break it up.
What's the gym today? But I'll tell you
I had a rough one. You know Jesus Christ.
Okay?
Why do I do this to myself?
What is it that makes you just you and
you know you're gaining weight just makes
you knock it on the fucking scale,
okay?
It just makes it worse.
If you're sitting there right now and
you know you're putting on weight and you
don't want to step on the
scale, do yourself the biggest
fucking favor right now.
Stop listening to this podcast.
Go in step on the scale
and see what the damages.
It's going to be a dope beat.
Fucking San Diego state.
They pulled away in the end
one way 19. Um, you know,
if you don't do it now,
you just going to keep going.
You're going to keep going further and
you're going to be as miserable as I am
right now. Fucking miserable. Um,
yeah, Jesus Christ. Why
did I do that to myself?
Jesus Christ. It looked like the fucking
Michelin man. I hide it. Well though,
I'll tell you,
you're going to hide a good 25 pounds
of fucking absolute shit with a fucking
button down shirt. You know that. Well,
that's what I used to say. It was your,
you're in sport coach shape, buttoned
down, shirt, shape, tee shirts, shape,
wifebeater shape,
no shirt shape.
And then the ultimate is no shirts
sitting down in shape. That's right there.
That is the deep be in shape pyramid.
All right.
Now and right now I am somewhere between,
I'm like buttoned down, shirt shape.
Um, I'll tell you, you really
want to discuss yourself,
you know,
cause you really gotta be disgusted with
yourself before you finally work out.
I find this is what you should do.
Stand shirtless in the mirror,
looking at yourself with a pair
of dad jeans in suspenders.
Okay. And, uh, the level discussed
you'll have for yourself,
you'll be dragging your ass to
the fucking gym. Like I, I am. Um,
and I, I apologize for how country
and be in this week. Um, anyways, um,
I'm heading back east,
coming up here in a little bit and um,
that's just one. If it's this,
it's still snowing in New York.
Is it melting or their ice dams?
Is the world ending back there?
MMM.
I have no fucking idea. I hadn't
back. They're coming back to as soon.
I just gotta hit the gym for the rest
of this fucking week and then I'll go to
New York next week and everything will
be fine and I'll be back there with all
the fucking animals that I used to drink
with and eat pizza late at night with.
And I'm just going to have to fucking
somehow plow through that shit.
But anyways, you don't want to
hear about that shit. Why don't we,
why don't we go fucking take a quick
look at some, uh, some world news,
some quarreled news, some
news from the quarreled. Um,
yeah, it's always, I never
go to a u s uh, new sites.
I try to stay away from those fucking
things cause I always hear all that shit
anyways, if I don't hear it on the
news, I hear comedians talking about it.
So I like going to fucking Algebra.
Xera I like checking out.
See what Al's talking about.
Son of Ukraine's ex president
drowns in a Russian lake.
The youngest son of Ukraine's,
former president Viktor Yanukovych.
You're know fit. What a fucking
great name you'll Milkovich Vick.
Viktor Yanukovych sounds like a
fucking hall of fame. Defensemen. Um,
has died after his vehicle,
punched through the ice near
the Russian Mongolian border.
The fuck was he doing all the way over
there and associate of the deposed
precedent set. I'll depose the
guy got booted. What did he do?
Did he stick a cigar?
And somebody taught on Sun set on
Sunday that the 33 year old victor,
Ian,
you know Kovich who had the same name
as his father was driving at the time of
his death.
Russian authorities have not identified
a driver who died on Friday when a mini
bus carrying six people smashed on thin
ice on Lake Baikal or confirm reports
that it was your Nocca bitches son. The
five passengers survived. Wait a minute.
Are you talking about this guy was
driving a bus? How the fuck are you,
the son of the president,
you're driving a bus carrying six people.
He must've been the rebel of the family.
You know,
it didn't want to follow in his
dad's footsteps and fuck this.
Yeah.
I'm going to go drive the fucking
hurts shuttle just north of Mongolia.
Is that what he did?
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking way to go.
I'll tell you what I will never always
amaze me is when fucking Ted Kennedy went
into that Damn Lake.
You know what I mean?
You'd think the weight of his giant head
alone. I mean that guy's head is like a,
was like a safe, I saw that guy
shook his hand one time. Um,
it's a long story right after I shook
Bill Clinton's hand, I was standing, um,
we're standing on the side of the road
in Boston and a buddy of mine wanted to
go down and see it. He's like,
all the presidents coming down,
let's go look at the fucking motorcade.
Me and this other fucking friend of mine
who was a total pothead and we could
give a shit. We were bleary
eyed. We went down there and uh,
Clinton came down the street and he
just wanted to see the motorcade.
And right as he was coming to drive by us,
the motor came dipped
down this fucking alley.
And then we're looking at a buddy
going, yeah, that was great, dude.
They fucking made a left turn.
And I,
we didn't see it and I got Nada and
i's going in there and make a speech or
probably being there for like an hour.
I'm going to go get a slice of pizza.
You guys want anything? We were
like, Nah, we're good, we're good.
So the dude who wants to see the motorcade
goes off to go see if get a fucking
slice of pizza. Me and the pod had a
fucking standing there not giving a shit.
All of a sudden the crowd
starts going nuts, right?
Going fucking crazy.
And the secret service guys were
behind this police get barricades.
Tell everybody, put their hands up,
keep your hands up all day and job.
We can ship. Keep your hands
up. They're like freaking out.
And all of a sudden he comes all slick
Willie walking up the fucking street high
five and people while the,
the,
the wellies limo is driving slowly along
next to him with the fucking door open
and walking right behind
him was fucking Ted Kennedy.
So a I high five Bill Clinton when he
was president before Monica Lewinsky.
This is his first term, right? Soft hands.
Soft like fucking,
I dunno what creepy.
Soft fucking hands.
Little hands. Little soft.
Fucking baby grows hands. But he did
have long piano flame playing fingers.
It was not a good experience.
It was getting who I didn't
want to be there. Right.
And then Ted Kennedy can want to
high five him and the sheer size,
the sheer mass of the guy's
head. I literally went, whoa.
You couldn't fucking believe the fact
that get that guy, his head was so big,
he never should have had a full
head of hair just other than this,
the sheer like surface
area of it that just,
even if he had a full head of hair,
it's not going to be a full head,
but that fucking head.
Yeah.
I'll tell you right now. Thank God that
guy didn't go bald, man. Jesus Christ,
that would have been us. That would
have been something to look at. Um,
so I shook his fucking hand and Jesus
Christ, he just looked like, you know,
yeah,
I know he was sober at that point, but
that guy, that guy lived a fucking, he,
I'll tell you know the rough one. You
know, fucking lost three of his brothers,
the thing that happened to his
sister and the whole fuck crazy.
And he goes in the lake, he
killed somebody. Oh my God.
Can you imagine his fucking
wife sleeping next to him?
How much does that guy talking to sleep?
Hi You, I had nothing to do with that.
Huh? I came in on the drag.
Huh? Jack it down. Get down.
Um, yeah, that's brutal. Anyways,
so then Bill Clinton
jumps in his fucking car.
Ted Kennedy jumps in with them and they
just fucking take off and everybody's
like, no, never just sort of walks away.
And then like all of that
took maybe like 17 seconds
and then everybody was gone and the whole
fucking thing was over. It was like,
it never happened.
And then we turn around and it comes,
my buddy coming up the street,
biting into a slice of pizza and navigate,
he bites in and then he like stopped mid
bite and he looks around and he goes,
ah, fuck. He's like,
did I miss it? He goes,
did I miss it? And I
go, yeah. And I go, uh,
I shook his hand,
just watch go. He came
walking up the street. I,
I shook his head and my
buddy goes, no, you didn't.
And then he looks over,
I look over and there's my pot had friend
whose like galloping in a circle and
he's just jumping up and down as
he's galloping and he's going, okay.
I shook it twice.
Ah, you could have seen the
look on that dude's face.
He was so fucking disappointed. We
didn't even tell them about Ted Kennedy.
MMM.
Anyways,
so there's that story.
There's that story for you.
MMM.
So anyways,
baseball season is starting up.
I'm wondering what my red sox
are going to do this year.
They went out and they spent
a bunch of fucking money.
Yankees haven't spent any money, man,
they're in a weird place right now.
Um,
but
I'm excited for baseball this year.
I hope it goes the way it did last year.
I'd like to see more
Baltimore, Tampa, Kansas City,
maybe Cleveland, you know,
Milwaukee. I liked all those,
all those fucking teams. You know what
I mean? I like, uh, I like seeing like,
you know, I like to see the Padres do
something. Somebody different, you know,
I like what the Dodgers did
last year too, but um, you know,
it's Kinda hard to be a fan of
a team that goes out and blows,
spends all the fucking money.
I know it's legal and that type of shit,
but it's just the way
that they run that league.
They should do it more like football,
which I hope they're doing.
And I hope last year was not like
this anomaly. Did I say that right?
I lost confidence as I was saying.
That's why I went. Anomaly anomaly.
Um Oh good, good. All the
Guy Clark Kellogg is going
to act out a basketball shot.
Thank God. Oh, here we go.
Yeah, do it. And your wing tips.
Now it comes the other guy.
Now what you want to do is pivot here.
Now you see if you do that,
that's called a travel.
Okay?
Like this. Does anybody learn the game
of basketball right here? Like you don't,
fuck did I just say the game of
basketball? Like a Michael Jordan?
MMM.
Oh Jesus Christ. Why do they do this? Who?
The person that came up with this like,
you know,
let's get half a football field in here
and have these old guys get down to
there. Three point stance. Hey, low. Well
why can't we do that with basketball?
That's what I love about hockey.
They don't,
they can't do it when they go out
there with street hockey sticks.
MMM.
It's so dumb. Why do they wear suits too,
by the way? They're fucking pro athletes.
Okay. Just get them there in
their sweat pants and t shirts.
Okay.
What's with the habit dash
I, you know something. I am like
36 minutes into this podcast.
I don't think I've liked one thing yet.
This is an all time like negative
podcasts and I'm putting Audi. I got,
I got to say something positive.
Yeah.
How about this?
Have you guys,
what was the last time you visited
the all things comedy network?
Go to all things, comedy.com and check
out all the podcasts that we have.
Um,
Fleet Bay Esparza this week.
He has boxer Roy Tapia.
I hope I said that right and UFC fighter.
Sean. Ah, Jesus. I'm going to get
killed in this one. Low floor,
low furl, low fuller Loie. F. F. L. E. R.
Um, we got Doug. Stan. Hope
we got the effect dude,
the all things come.
All things.
Comedy network is the blessed
podcasting network out there. Bar none.
If you look at the quality of shows,
Ari Shaffir, Tom, Papa, you kidding me?
Harlan Williams.
Bert Kreischer
your mom's house. Come on man. We got
fucking everybody on this thing. Uh,
quality control here. Just go onto the
podcast network, all things comedy,
and just start clicking on some
podcasts and I guarantee you a,
you're going to have a good time and
I'll probably lose some listeners,
but whatever it gives a shit as long as
the money goes to other comedians. Right.
Um, all right, let's get into
some questions for the week here.
This is the advertising. This is not
what I want. All right, here we go. Um,
all right,
and by the way,
if you'd like to send emails
to the Monday morning podcast,
um,
the email is bill at the [inaudible]
podcast.com bill@thenmpodcast.com and if
you'd like to follow us on Twitter,
it's at the m m podcast
at the m m podcast.
Uh, Clark Kellogg acting out of Fucking
Layup, Huh? Jesus Christ. All right.
Thursday afternoon, Thursday
afternoon, Monday morning podcast. Um,
I'm been doing those lately.
I'll do another one this
week, dear Billy overtime.
Thanks for the extra podcasts.
My wife and I have a longer commute on
Mondays and Fridays and a couple months
ago she said,
how about you write in and ask bill
if he can do another one on Fridays?
I told her not to get greedy and that
we're lucky the man hasn't retired yet.
Jesus am I that old. Lo
and behold, you did it.
And since it's the Thursday
afternoon podcast, it perfectly,
it's perfectly wrapped for us to
listen to listen to Friday mornings.
Love you. Love Nia. Thanks again.
Couple of commuters from Ontario.
Nice. Ontario, Canada. Uh,
you, uh, you maple leaf fans.
You know who else is in
Ontario? Toronto. Ontario.
Okay.
I already forget. What the fuck
is. Quebec. Which providence
is that in? Not Quebec.
You idiot. I mean Ottawa is
Ottawa and Quebec or Ontario.
I Dunno.
But I do know it's the capitol and at
the fucking river freezes over and you
could skate to work. And I've been
there. How about that? Is that,
isn't that enough for you? Um,
well thank you for listening. Um,
I'm actually looking at a Toronto date,
possibly in the fall. It all depends.
I've got a little bit of acting
work. Alright. Oh Billy Shakespeare.
It was going to do possibly another
movie or to, uh, later on this year.
And uh, oh, I want to thank everybody
who went out to go see Zam beavers. Uh,
please continue to see it. Uh, got
a lot of hilarious emails about it,
saying that it was funny.
It made fun of Zombie movies and had
respect for it and they actually jumped
like three or four times. It was
legitimately scary. A lot of nudity in it,
you know, old school
fucking horse shit. Um,
once again directed by a Jordan Rubin
stand up comic that I started out with a
long time ago. So a that always
helps. That helps me out. You know,
if shit that I'm in does well, so thank
you guys for checking it out. And um,
if you don't get a chance to
check it out in movie theaters,
please a download legally.
Um,
so you can see more raw
movies about rodents in farm.
It's to turn into zombies.
Um, by the way, I watched it again.
You got to see Sam Rockwell and moon.
I swear to God, you got to
see that fucking thing. I'm
not a big Scifi guy and uh,
it was so good a knee and I were actually
saying that we want to watch more
Scifi.
So if you have some good Saifai um,
am I slowly turning into a fucking what
does that, what does that think? Comicon.
Am I gonna be one of those people?
I'm already dressing up
like drummers and shit.
What's the difference between
that and dressing up like Spock?
Okay.
I don't know. All right.
Woman in the warehouse.
I love when I get letters from females.
I never get them on this thing. Okay.
Woman in the warehouse. Dear
Bill, I'm a 27 year old. Yeah.
And I work in a warehouse in
Philly. Hey, good for you.
I used to work in warehousing.
Okay.
It's one of my favorite fucking jobs
I ever had and I always said that if I
wasn't going to get older and I wasn't,
I wasn't
going to turn 30 someday.
Um,
I would have stayed there forever
because it was such a fun fucking job.
Whose physical?
You got a good workout in.
Everybody that worked in the
warehouse was either a class clown,
a struggling musician,
uh,
a fucking drug addict.
It was,
everybody was a character out there
and they were all fucking, yeah,
hilarious.
I loved,
I never understood wanting to get into
the carpet area and get yourself a little
Michael J. Fox, you know, what was that?
Sick commies, family ties, dressing
up like him with your Goddamn loafers,
you know, acting like you're
in there making decisions.
The decisions have been made
for you. You know, you go in,
you sit in your little half
a fucking office and you
and you act accordingly. Um,
he says,
I,
she says I work in a warehouse in Philly
and involves some manual labor and I
like it. It's just part time. Um,
as I'm getting my master's in English,
they like,
what are you working at a ups
that was the big thing back then.
$8 an hour to fucking work harder than
you'll ever work and your life on loading
those trucks fucking thing heavy as 70
boxes and then you have like an entire
exhaust system that job's a motherfucker.
I'm the guys in the warehouse, so cool.
But they always act like I'm going to
rat them to HR if I hear them make jokes
about women, et cetera. What can
I say to end this? Any advice?
Um, well, first of all, your cool
if you don't mind that they do it.
Do you have to understand,
um,
that's the climate right now is that
if you make any sort of any joke,
if you say anything about
women other than, you know,
we'll, I'll tell you it's a damn shame
that more women don't, blah, blah, blah.
If you say anything about women,
the way you say hello to him and he,
all they have to do is just say that
you're making them uncomfortable. Um,
and next thing you know,
they're losing their job and then they
have this fucking creepy sex thing on
their fucking resume,
sexual harassment or some shit like that.
So, uh, I dunno if I hear them
make any jokes about, well,
what can I say to end this?
Any advice? Um, you know what?
I wouldn't get involved in it.
Okay.
I wouldn't get, I don't know why
you want to get involved in it.
I don't know why you want to open
that Pandora's box. No Pun intended.
Just stay away from it. All right? Don't,
you're going to get them in
trouble or worst case scenario,
you're going to be one of those
people. Oh, I'm totally cool then.
And then uh oh well I'm not with that.
How could you say that? And then you go,
actually yeah, go to HR. And I'm not
saying you're one of these women,
but you are a woman. So you know
what I'm talking about. All right.
Talking about the old bait and switch
with the hoo ha there. So stay away.
Don't go fucking, you know, don't
go over there. Bite in the apple.
All right. The parameters have been
set by a bunch of fucking people.
Bitch moaning and complaining
and people adhere to those rules.
So every one of those guys by you
opening the doors saying, guys,
I don't care if you fucking talk
about women in a derogatory way.
You're opening a door for
all of them to get fired.
So it seems to me that you want to be
one of the guys and you want to be cool.
So if you want to do that,
then just fucking respect the fact that
they're respecting you and don't pick at
that scab because you're going to
get it demond trouble. All right.
They go, um, well too.
That makes me a god. It makes me wish
I was still in my twenties. Again,
there was nothing better than that.
You worked in the warehouse all day and
once a week you played softball against
some other fucking warehouse. And at
the end of the game, UAVs the best.
We used to go to this
fucking, uh, you know,
a Massachusetts like every
other town just has like,
you know, they have placed that
claims, they have the best bar pizza.
So it would almost be like a small pizza
that you get at some chain thing. And,
um, we had the place where,
where I was at, which I'm
not going to say the name of,
cause I don't want fucking bunch of
people going there. So when I go there,
I got to stand in line. But, um, we
used to go to the original location.
It's since changed in, of course
people bitched and moaned. Okay Dude,
all the original flavors in those
old, on your oven. Right. You know,
um, it's like, no, it isn't.
All your memories are there.
Your grandfather took
you there and you're sad.
So now you can say the
pizza doesn't taste as good.
They fucking literally moved
like 20 fucking minutes
down the street. All right,
grow up. Not even that. It's like a
fucking six minute drive. So anyways,
we used to go there afterwards and uh,
oh it's the fucking best.
You worked all day,
you played softball and he just
slam like fucking six beers,
eat a pizza
and then drive home.
Cause it was the fucking eighties, you
know, drive home buzzed, which was stupid,
but you know,
and a pass out,
wake up and do it all over again.
MMM.
I always enjoy, I enjoy manual
labor jobs that are inside. I was,
I did not enjoy manual labor outside
just because I would get sunburned like a
motherfucker. But, um,
I did like driving around what
people when they will plow a plowing,
plowing driveways and going
out and shoveling snow. But a,
you really fuck up your back.
That's how Larry Bird, same thing.
Larry Bird blacktop, his
parent's driveway. And you know,
that little stupid little stick fucking
handle thing that's built for a guy my
size. He was like six, 10.
Okay.
Bent over at the fucking waste doing
that. His back was never the same. But uh,
whenever I hear that Shit,
I don't know.
It makes me happy that I have
a job where I don't have to
fucking lifted anything.
You know, it's funny,
I was making fun of Bill Clinton's
fucking soft hands. I have soft hands.
The only cows is, I have on my hands
at this point is from doing pull ups.
Oh, Billy soft dance. All
right. Uh, repeat television.
Hey Bill. I watched TV like every other
American and citizen of the world.
I watch a lot of Seinfeld
and Simpson reruns.
I was wondering what
shows you wrote shoes,
what shows you're a,
you're able to watch over and over again.
Also what shows could you watch as
a kid that were before your time?
Oh, what I, that I, I was not mature
enough to watch over groundbreaking.
Um,
last a great question.
Let's see what shows can I watch over
and over and over again? The Simpsons,
you already said them.
MMM.
Let's see.
You know what it is,
there's not a lot of them
because I really got into sports,
you know, in my teens. So they were,
I used to watch family
ties. I would watch, um,
I would watch cheers.
I tried to watch the Cosby show,
but I couldn't stand his wife on
the show when she would do that.
Stupid joke was she knew we'll clear
it's going to do this and then clear the
clear.
My hated the thing.
And then I hated that overly cutesy
shit he would do with the kids.
Like it was a Jello commercial. And, um,
but I did like the show when I would
actually give it a fucking chance.
I liked the show. Um, but I, I dunno,
I just,
there was just,
they was such a goody goody f it
was like the fucking Brady bunch.
I just can't get into that shit. You
know, it means it's good. He good. He,
his family ties was, I at
least liked it. Michael J.
Fox character was kind of a dick.
He was like a Republican,
which I thought was different, you know.
And that was probably another awful one.
I can't remember, I would
say, but the shit that I
actually go back and watch, um,
it's just all shit from
my childhood. Um, I like,
I'll watch an episode of chips now.
I love watching ships whenever it
comes on because I live in la now,
so I try to guess which highway they're
on, what, which one they're filming.
Okay.
Um, which one they're filming
on. I'll watch Charlie's angels.
I guess that was ahead of my time.
I will watch Charlie's angels.
MMM.
Beretta, which was considered
really violent swat. The rookies,
$6 million man. Um,
those were all the show.
Happy days. I spoke to one
corn ball, one that I watched
and then I would watch reruns
of the monkeys. I saw every
episode of the monkeys,
every episode of the Brady Bunch. Uh,
and then I watched all the Westerns,
bonanza, big valley.
What's the one with the,
the guy would fucking the rifle man.
Stupid son used to always call him Paul.
He used to drive me nuts.
Fucking do with cry like every fucking
three episodes. I couldn't stand him.
Batman.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. I've wasted a lot
of fucking time, didn't I? Yeah,
mostly shit back then. But then in the
90s, I started doing standup in like 1992.
So I never even really saw Seinfeld. I
just remember hearing about it. By 93,
it blew up and everyone was talking about
him was on the cover of rolling stone
and shit.
But I didn't really watch it until it
came into reruns because then it came on
during a time where I
could actually see it. Um,
what do I watch now? I watch archer, uh,
I watch last man on earth.
I Dunno now in the TV
watching is different now.
So He'd go on Netflix and
you're like Binge Watch.
Like I still haven't started better
call Saul. And I know that, you know,
maybe next week when I go on the road
I'm going to watch the pilot episode in
the second one,
I have every other one tape.
What happened to me was that show started
when I was overseas and I forgot to
set my fucking DVF. So, uh,
I got to get caught up in that
old Joey roses is in it. Joe Doe,
Rosa where the SOM Dan and
there's something, something.
So a lot of people have been asking me,
hey bill,
are you going to be on better call Saul?
And this is what I'll tell
you if you guys keep watching.
I have a good feeling that eventually,
cause it's a prequel,
the closer he gets to meet and Walter
White at some point I might drop at my
character might come back. That's all I
know. Okay. I'm not in the writer's room.
I have no idea. So, uh, if you
could, if you could keep watching it,
I'd appreciate it. Listen to
me is, I haven't even started.
I'm starting this week.
All right. That's my promise
to you and I'm going to keep,
no,
I did.
Um, all right, thanks. And Go
fuck yourself. All right. Camping.
Hey Bill,
you ever do any serious or casual camping?
Is that something you
think you could do you,
but is that something you think you
could Nia into? You mean talk Nia into,
um,
I've gone on some field trips as a kid
and recently with friends and I'm trying
to help my girlfriend to go.
She's hesitant.
I assured her it would be warm weather,
camping,
that'd be swimming and smores and all
that, all that stuff. Thoughts on camping.
Um,
and whether a chick should just relax
for a weekend without a curling iron.
Go Fuck Yourself. Uh, always one. Yeah.
Say that. Um, the y
camp, no, I respect it.
But, um, I think I went camping once.
I told this story before I met this
chicken at college and she's like,
we were going camping and
I was like, well, I want to
hook up with the ASL. Yeah,
I'll go. And, uh, I don't
know what happened. I seen
all, I'm out there, I'm like,
fucking 30. I'm hanging with these
college kids. And I was like,
what the fuck am I doing out here?
We got hammered and nothing ended up
happening. And I think I puked in a tent,
which means I did puke in a tent, but
I'm embarrassed. So even years later,
I had to say,
I think I puked in a tent.
Um,
so that's my experience.
Um, I don't know. On my bucket list is
getting mauled is not on my bucket list,
so I'm not into like, I would
go camping if I had, uh,
a fucking glock in a rifle.
I would do that,
but I don't like that shit
where I'm sleeping in a tent
and then a bear comes up
and smells my food or something and then
looks at the tent and can smell me and
not the tent. And me become like
a fruit roll up or a burrito. Oh,
Billy burrito. And that thing just
starts biting my head. Fuck that.
Fuck that. Um, but I do respect people
that actually go out there and, um,
no out of fucking rough
it and live off the land.
You know what you state of the art
tense in your fucking heated socks.
But as far as your girlfriend
not wanting to go, uh, why maker?
Why maker? She's going to be miserable,
which is going to make you miserable.
Why don't you just have that be the thing
that you do that's just separate time
from her absence makes the heart grow
fonder and then you guys come back
together. Why don't you, why don't
you just do that instead of trying to,
trying to talk her into that shit.
And I would never try to talk
my wife into that stuff. Uh,
I've asked her a couple times and she
has no fucking desire on any level.
She's a city girl. She does not
want to go fucking being a tent.
You want to rent a house by a lake,
you know,
with windows and doors and a fireplace.
She's all about it. But you know,
as far as like going out there eating
beans with a knife out of a fucking can
yet. No, she's not into that. All right,
let's read the last couple of advertisers
here and then we'll wrap up the thing
here.
Um,
what do we got here? Oh, dollar
shave club, everybody. All right.
Have you been listening to this podcast?
You may have heard me talking
about dollar shave club.com.
The company that delivers amazing
raises for a few bucks a month.
I know a razor that costs
a few bucks delivery,
a great shave also seems too
good to be true, right? Well,
listen up, but you really have to do
what this copy makes sense. No sense.
But you really have to try the razors,
the dollar shave club.com raisers.
We'll give you the most amazing
shave you've had in years.
Don't pay triple the price when you
can get fantastic shaved the shape.
You can get a fantastic shaved delivered
for just a couple of dollars a month.
Jesus felt you'd have to be
an idiot to keep over pay.
I'm a massive, I hate this
paragraph. Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Don't be fooled by the price.
These razors are legit and you'll
and you'll never go back. Plus Dave,
I got the classic Dr Carver's.
Easy Shave
bye.
It's phenomenal. If you're still
using old fashioned shave foam,
you're a loser and I bad for you.
Try Dollar Shave club.com/bird today
to get started. You'll wish you had.
You had sooner.
That's dollar shave club.com/bird dollar
shave club.com/burr I gotta tell you,
man,
of everything that I've advertised,
that's the one thing
everybody is going crazy for.
[inaudible] and I have not
had one bad tweet about it.
Everybody has said it's awesome,
so I can really stand behind that product.
Man, I don't know why nobody thought
to do that sooner. Fucking brilliant.
I do remember years ago that somebody
came out with a thing that would sharpen
your razors, your, your,
your razor blades so you wouldn't have
to throw him out and that thing came and
went really quick. I think they got
bought out by like Gillette or something.
I would guess it's like, dude,
don't fucking sell that thing.
You're going to cut into our profits.
So they just went up and you know,
just slap the guy in the face with a
bunch of hundreds and the dude probably
took it, you know. Anyways,
oh, Kansas is playing.
This is my fucking team. I don't watch
a lot of college who, but Kansas. Uh,
one of my bucket list things is to go
to a home game out there in Kansas. Um,
oh, nice. I'm almost done here.
I'm watching this fucking game
they played in Wichita state. Oh,
it's a little in state rivalry
here. Eight to five, Kansas early.
Um,
stamps.com everybody,
when you think about the best
time to go to the post office,
you're probably guessing before work,
after work or during lunch, wrong.
That's when it's most crowded.
Everyone's going at the same time.
What you need to do is
call in sick from work. Uh,
the truth is there's no convenient
time to go to the post office.
That's why you need stamps.com
with stamps.com access.
You can access all the services of
the post office right from your desk.
You can buy and print official US postage
for any letter or package using your
computer or printer.
Then just hand it to your mail carrier.
It's so easy and I saw
you, I stretch. I ran.
Now Sean de Grasse. Um, and unlike
the post office stamps.com is open 24,
seven with no lights so you can get your
mailing and shipping done whenever it's
convenient for you. I use stamps.com
I use stamps.com dot, dot,
dot. I guess I fill it in
to send out all my posters,
which I'm going to do right now.
I'm actually looking at the first draft
of the Billy Bible belt poster. Uh,
it's going to be great.
It's going to be funny.
I'm going to autograph all of them.
And a, I will be standing out,
whoring myself out,
um,
selling those things after every
show from my big southern tour.
I cannot fucking wait for this tour.
It's why I'm getting in shape because I
know I'm going to gain 10 pounds in this
tour. The amount of fun that I'm going
to have and a about a week out, um,
I'm going to have a,
uh,
some sort of thing either through my
email or some of my Twitter account.
What you guys tell me where to go
and get my dinner every night. Um,
and we want to go to mom and pop
fucking places and when they're awesome,
we will not tell people about it on
the podcast. We will not blow it up.
We'll just you a thank you letter.
All right. Anyways, right now,
here's my last name,
birth for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in,
mmm,
my last name, birth for this
special offer. For some reasons,
some of the copy got cut off
here@stamps.com it's great.
We've been using it forever. I'm using it.
It's awesome. Check it out now. Stamps,
stamps.com/ [inaudible]
Berbee you are are. All
right, well that is the, uh,
that is the podcast for this week.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I want to thank everybody that's been
writing in love hearing from the ladies
and um,
yeah,
I dunno. I got a crazy week coming
up and I'll, I'll be telling you,
telling you about it, hopefully on
Thursday. Remember the Thursday podcast?
Oh, Billy red face. Just checking in,
seeing how you're doing on pay day. Um,
all in once again, I know I've
liked this for two weeks in a row,
but checkout Sam Rockwell and moon
and also check out, uh, Chris, uh,
I hate Christian late there.
Um,
that I moon.
I'm actually going to buy that on DVD.
That's how much I enjoyed
that fucking movie. It's, I,
I just can't imagine how
difficult that must have been.
MMM.
To shoot, to perform and all that type
of thing. It just, just an awesome,
awesome movie. All right. That's it.
Go Bruins for the love of Christ.
Let's get that last playoff spot and
I'm all right. I'm just babbling here.
That's it. I'll go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you next week.